THEY DID AGAINSTF
DOWLING, HE CHASES IT AGAINST
LUNDESTROM WHO FEEDS IT UP THE G
VANCOUVER THE YOUNGSTER, LUNDES.
AS THE CANUCKS GLOVE OF GIBSON,H
MILLER NOW, TOM LINDHOLM
AND CARRIES AHEAD AND NOW A
THREE-ON-TWO SHORTHANDED AND
THEN ONTO THE NOW SENT OUT OF P,
AND PEARSON NOW OUT OF THE DIGGG
FOR THAT PUCK.
AND NOW IT S S SHOULDER OF GIBSN
ACROBATIC GOALTENDER, SCRAMBLING
HERE TO GARLAND AND MYERS NOW S.
OUR CRACK STATISTICI
COME WAS, DRO OF HIS PAD AND
SKATE BUT WITITNE AND THE DUCKS,
HUGHES, MILIL HERE.
AND MANSON, THROWING IT USED TO,
D
ELIAS PETTERSSON WITH A SHOT AND
IT IS IN! CAN SEE MANSON GRABBIG
HEADED WIDE BUT MILLER NOW IN
AND THEIR LONE
OVERTIME VICTORY COURTESY WILL
BRING IT OUT.
AND IT MILANO,
PETTERSSON BLOCKING IT, AND
MILANO, AGAIN, AND THAT FEED
GIG
A THRILLER, 3-2 IN OVERTIME.IVED
TERRY